did I embellish my resume yes I did and
I'm sorry George Santos George who we
know is a friend
and he's known as Anthony the boulder to
me so I don't know where George Santos
came in today I think but that's what it
says here I've always known him as
Anthony devalder I've never known him as
George Santos I've always joked with
friends and circles even with in the
campaign I'd say guys I'm Jewish
remember I was raised Catholics but in
Brazil a local performer claims Santos
was Katara Rivage and that he once
performed as a drag queen Something New
York Congressman strongly denies so they
sent me to a good prep school so and
which was Horseman uh prep in the Bronx
a Horus man spokesperson told CNN the
school has no record of Santos Santos
also claimed to have graduated from
Baruch in 2010 but now he says he never
graduated from any college but I put
myself through college and got an MBA
from NYU and I have zero debt I actually
went to school on uh on a volleyball
scholarship he's got two knee
Replacements he didn't have these guys
too that's sad how young is he he didn't
have knee Replacements said he owned 13
different properties when he's never
been a landlord or claiming in a resume
he gave to local Republican leaders back
in 2020 that he worked at Goldman Sachs
and Citigroup he did not he called
himself the head guy in the New York
office he said he was an executive and
interesting uh he also claimed that he
was posting for all of these customers
these massive massive returns another
bucket of misleading information seems
to be pulled from thin air like Santos's
completely made up claim that he started
a non-profit to rescue cats and dogs
there's no record of that ever happening
veteran Richard ossoff now claims that
in 2016 George Santos promised to help
him raise funds for his six sick dogs
life-saving surgery but the money
disappear he disappeared with the money
rather after three thousand dollars in
funds were raised he also lied about his
mom saying on Twitter that 911 claimed
her life she wasn't even in the country
during the attack which I happened to at
the time have people that worked for me
me in the club we my company at the time
we lost four employees that were that
were at Pulse Nightclub law enforcement
officials in Brazil will likely
reinstate fraud charges against the
congressman elect George Santos he's
accused of spending nearly 700 out of a
stolen checkbook using a fake name now
there's an old Wikipedia page of
Politico found claiming for instance he
had a role on a popular Disney Channel
program Hannah Montana that there was uh
one campaign fundraising staffer who did
impersonate as Kevin McCarthy's Chief of
Staff to top donors to raise money for
George Sanders's campaign they're very
proud of my grandparents story my
grandfather fleeing Ukraine spleen
Stalin's persecution going to to Belgium
finding Refuge there marrying my
grandmother then fleeing Hitler records
from the Holocaust Museum and the
International Center on Nazi persecution
show no mention of Santos's grandparents
he once claimed to be one of the first
people in the United States to be
diagnosed with covet 19. untruth
surfacing regarding Senator Chuck
Schumer's mother in a podcast from last
may she lives in my district and she had
a mouthful when I knocked on her door
asking her for her vote so she says I
don't know what's happened to my son he
used to be a good man George Santos
claims that he was mugged right behind
where I'm standing on Fifth Avenue in
broad daylight in the middle of the
afternoon in the summer and that the
muggers took his watch his briefcase and
his shoes I'm George Santos and I
approve this message